he's the head coach at Loyola of Chicago
had a great run in the tournament he
supporter Moser joins us on the program
coach how are you I'm great Dan how are
you I'm doing great how are you are
where are you I should say I'm back in
Chicago because I headed out after
Sunday after the game and I just got
back with my family and uh watch the
game with my three boys my daughter and
my wife at my house last night break
down the game last night what did you
see from a coaching perspective I tell
you what then you start leave defenses
and you know with especially the
beginning just how how long they are and
just fundamentally close out so well but
the thing about doing overs offense in
Michigan they go downhill with their
drives I mean they space you but when
they drive like Stephen sends out I mean
he's not just a shooter when he drives
he puts it you know we call it body up
bodies and he drops his shoulder and he
goes downhill and then they ticket there
they're very unselfish they got they
space the floor everybody can suit it
and that's so hard when you get all five
guys that can shoot the three because
you've been it's been that downhill
driving become so effective it I think I
thought this end was coming really good
I know Villanova was just almost
impossible to beat last night but
Michigan I saw firsthand their defense
is just really really good what did you
know about D Vincenzo's you know it's
funny then I during the year I saw him
play a game about two weeks before the
season ended and he had one of the same
kind of first half I'm trying to think
who it was against it was in the Big
East and it was uh and I just I just
remember how passionate the kid is I
remember how quick a trigger and
confident he is but I also said you know
he's just not this kid because it suited
you can sit with reigns he can make
contested shots but he can go down hill
off the bounce and if you saw last night
you know he hit a couple threes then he
had Michigan State or Michigan's defense
kind of leaning and then that's when he
went downhill and they got finished at
the rim
he's not one of those guys like like me
that finished at the bottom of the net
you know he he gets down there any
finishes at the rim and you know I think
he's really good high-energy
competitors hell could you watch last
night's game
now not thinking about being there in
the national title again you know Dan
that's I had bunch of my close friends
that know me well they you know want to
entice me like don't don't think about
what if think about what is and he's a
coaching friend and I thought that was
really good advice and it was tough you
know I'll sit back you know once or
weeks from now and just kind of reflect
on what we did with our our university
in our program but you know you're in
that moment and all you can think about
is attainment for you and and trying to
get where you want to go and that's to
win at all and it was tough we had a
10-point lead and we had a barrage of
turnovers we had a five minute stretch I
thought that really cost us but you know
I was watching it and you know it was
tough it was tough but she had to give
credit to Michigan and going over those
those are the better teams and they
deserve to be there too last night the
three-point shot in college basketball
what it is now what it means now and
where are we headed do you think you
know I think it's such a weapon and
you're seeing more and more teams user
because it's it's not as far as you know
with kids strength and range now you
know the NBA three is is counter to play
strains when you stop and look at the
pace you see where these guys at our
level or suiting it but where it's at
right now I mean you got to utilize it
we don't I can't stand the 17 foot 18
foot shot right in front of the three
you know I want a space and our space is
shooting I want recruit shooters from
what we did this year about Ola we were
trying to play with at least four guys
in the floor that could shoot the three
at all times and I think it's exciting I
think it spaces the floor it creates
better offense I think with the new
rules in the last couple of years that
they implemented with the no hand
checking the free of a movement you see
in better offense is driving kicking and
I think it's a weapon that I think
you've got to be we love utilizing it
Porter Moser the Loyola Chicago head
coach joining us Continental Tire
Coach's Corner how many schools have
reached out to you or your agent I
waited five minutes but you know let's
like hit anybody you're a hot ticket
right now
well you know right now I hate to be
like today I love my ad I love Chicago
things reached out well learned we're
talking and you know that's kind of
where it is right now and I tell you it
money there's just you know we we spent
so much energy my staff and I building
us from a grassroots build up and I feel
like we got it in a good place they can
even move forward and so I really
haven't thought about it like honest to
god and so through this tournament and
then attended all the some of the
questions have been coming yesterday and
today and I sat down had breakfast with
my ADC watching like I really like we
got a great relationship and then uh and
we're gonna go from there
yeah I know it it I I hate this time of
the year I love this story of loyal to
Chicago but every year it feels like
there's a school that has a run and then
you know the coach is not going to stay
and I know it's a business as well and
you got to do what's right for you know
all your kids but hopefully it's a shock
a smart situation where he stayed at VCU
for a few more years and you got a good
team coming back and a chance to do some
more damage there so I know it's a lot
to think about but you know I sort of
know it is then you're right you're
right I had a great coaching friend who
has stayed at a school at this level and
said don't run from happiness and I'm
happy I am I know I hope all this moves
in the right direction for my family and
I but I'm happy I am we've spent so much
time investing I do believe this I
played at a Jesuit school I played a
crate and I watched what how that needs
the meteoric rise or vassal program and
how the community and everything and
Creighton will never go backwards I mean
that that program is just skyrocketing
and and you know there's a lot of like
that Gonzaga and we've got a lot of work
to do to get to that point but we made a
two-step this year and and I'm from here
you know I'm a Catholic kid from Chicago
who grew up here is Chicago sports fan I
love all the die-hard sports fan and so
I am happy and I'm hoping this moves in
the right direction what famous person
do people mistake you for
[Laughter]
it was hard to wear the final four hat I
don't wear hats while I put my final
sore head on Kansas State and it just
looked like I had two frisbees popping
out the side of my head that I got do
you look like it and did somebody say
you look like somebody you know anybody
you've never been mistaken for somebody
no I
Wow no no I got trying to think I have
it I mean I haven't you need a winter
hat you don't don't wear a baseball like
a Final Four a winter hat that you can
wear that kind of cover up the ears a
little bit there coach that's great I do
you know one of those maybe maybe your
muscle you know just robe thrown back
hey congrats it was a lot of fun and
hopefully you have some opportunities
there to decide upon and no reload for
next year thanks so much big fan always
thanks for having me on
Thank You coach that's a Porter Moser
loyal to Chicago head basketball coach
Continental Tire Coaches Corner
whether you're a student alumni are
all-around fan Continental Tire has a
tire that can get you to the big game
did you know they're a proud supporter
of 32 college basketball teams across
the United States it's true Continental
Tire shares your passion for the game
show them your passion using the hashtag
ode to basketball for more information
visit Continental Tire comm for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]